What if everything you thought you knew
about nonfiction writing was wrong?
Well, after 10 years of teaching
academic and professional writing, I've
got to come clean. Some of the advice
that I taught most confidently has
actually been making my students worse.
And this advice we still see everywhere
online. So common that it's even being
built into the AI tools that you're
using now. So here are five pieces of
writing advice that I've changed my mind
about. Starting with one that's been
shared as so many times that it's
basically become law. You see this all
over the place, but here it is. This
sentence has five words. Here five more
words. Five word sentences are fine, but
several together become monotonous.
Listen to what is happening. The writing
is getting boring. The sound of it
drones. It's like a stuck record. The
ear demands some variety. Now listen. I
vary the sentence length and I create
music. Music. The writing sings. It has
a pleasant rhythm, a lilt, a harmony. I
use short sentences. And I use sentences
of medium length. And sometimes when I
am certain the reader is rested, I will
engage him with a sentence of
considerable length. A sentence that
burns with energy and builds with all
the impetus of a crescendo. The roll of
the drums, the crash of the symbols.
Sounds that say, "Listen to this. It is
important." So write with a combination
of short, medium, and long sentences.
Create a sound that pleases the reader's
ear. Don't just write words, write
music. Now you've probably seen this
meme before and look, I get it. It's
clean, it's visual, and it makes the
invisible structures beneath the writing
obvious. And as a meme, it's packaged
for virality, which is why it gets
shared so much despite being so wrong.
If you think about it for more than a
second, the problem here is that
sentence length has no relationship
whatsoever to readability. I've seen
long sentences that lose nothing in
clarity or grace, provided that they're
well coordinated and balanced. And just
as well, I've seen short sentences that
are completely incomprehensible. The
variety of your sentence lengths makes
no difference on reader comprehension.
But that's not exactly the claim of this
meme now, is it? The meme says that a
sentence length has something to do with
music. And that to me is even more
bizarre. At best, sentence length is
like a proxy for rhythm. So, you can
have short staccato sentences that might
be something like high tempo, and long
sentences would be more of a quarter
note, I guess. But honestly, this
metaphor really breaks down for me. Now,
if music is actually what you want in
your prose, then you'd be better off
listening to James Joyce than to Gary
Provost. Provost? Provost? Joyce said
that writing was like music. So, if you
wanted to write a chord, then you might
open a story with a man who has a kidney
disease. And then later, a character
who's eating kidneys. And then later
still, somebody gets kicked in the
kidneys. Each scene echoes the same
motif. That's music. But that has
nothing to do with sentence length and
everything to do with thematic
coherence. And so, the deeper issue with
the Gary Provost meme, and the thing
that really made me change my mind about
it, is that it directs your attention to
the surface of your writing rather than
the substance. Writers who become
preoccupied with surface features like
sentence length or grammar structures or
word choice, they miss the deeper issue,
which is the meaningful content that
those forms are carrying. A sentence is
long because it has a lot to carry, and
a sentence is short when the point lands
and there's nothing left to say. So, if
you listen to Gary Provost and try to
inject variety into your sentence
lengths, then you're not going to create
music. Making a short sentence longer
just because it follows three other
short sentences will not create music.
It's just padding and fluff. So, please,
the next time that you see this meme get
shared, and you will see it, do me a
favor. Respond with a comment and point
out that this is not advice about music.
It's advice about word count, and
readers do not give a toss about word
count. It has no relationship to music
or to the value that you create for
readers. Now, for the second piece of
writing advice that I've had to
reconsider. So, I used to believe this
so strongly that I had a rule in my
writing classes, active voice only. Now,
unless my student could give me a
compelling argument for why the passive
voice was necessary, they must write in
the active voice. And so, in case you
don't know, the passive voice is a
sentence like the experiment was
conducted instead of I conducted the
experiment. The results were observed
instead of the scientist observed the
results. And it was found that instead
of this study found. And so, these
students were using the passive voice
constantly for two reasons. First, they
were mainly native Korean speakers and
in the Korean language, the grammatical
subject is optional, whereas it's
necessary in English. So, whenever you
translate a sentence from Korean to
English through a translator, they use
Papago here, but something like Google
Translate, then you're not giving the
translator the grammatical information
it needs, and so it just defaults into
the passive voice. But second, they were
also scientists and engineers, and
there's this idea in science that you
want your work to be objective, and you
don't want to give in to your own
subjective bias. And so, one way to
reflect that value in your prose is by
taking the subject out of the sentence
and using the passive voice. And so,
when I made this rule about always using
the passive voice, I thought I was being
helpful. I thought I was helping them
write better. But actually, I was just
enforcing a rule that I hadn't thought
hard enough about. And so, what I didn't
understand at the time is that the
passive voice is not inherently weak.
The passive voice is just another tool
in the writer's toolkit, this one for
controlling agency, which just means who
appears in the sentence and whether
they're named at all. And so, a quick
example here. In the last edition of
Charles Darwin's The Origin of Species,
Darwin closes with this famous passage.
It says, "There is a grandeur in this
view of life, with its several powers
having been originally breathed into a
few forms or into one. And that whilst
this planet has gone on cycling on
according to the fixed law of gravity
from so simple a beginning, endless
forms, most beautiful and most
wonderful, have been and are being
evolved." So, "are being evolved" that's
the passive voice. And notice that in
this version, it's agentless, which is
to say we don't know who is doing the
evolving. These people are being
evolved. It's a little bit like saying a
mistake was made. All right, who made
the mistake? Something caused the
mistake to happen, and in this sentence,
something caused the beings to evolve,
but Darwin doesn't want to name it. But
now look what happens in the third
edition of The Origin of Species. He
revises the passage to this. It says,
"There is a grandeur in this view of
life, with its several powers having
been originally breathed by the creator
into a few forms or into one. And so
that switch makes explicit what was only
implicit before. And so that single
decision about agency, that's not better
or worse, weaker or stronger. Instead,
it changes the entire meaning and the
closing note of the book. So depending
on where you stand with Darwin,
evolution, and God, that change either
confirms your faith or sharpens your
resistance to it. Now, imagine if Darwin
had been one of my students, and he had
to follow this rule for my writing class
about always using the active voice.
Every reader would have been pushed
harder in whichever direction they were
already leaning, because there's no
ambiguity. There's just a bold
declaration about who Darwin thinks set
up this whole system. So the passive
voice as a writing tool gave Darwin
breathing room. It allowed him to
mention the action without explicitly
naming who performed the action of that
verb. And so the active voice would have
taken that away. And so what I know now
is that the active voice and the passive
voice are not better or worse than each
other. They're just different, and they
produce different effects in specific
readers. Those are writer decisions, and
those decisions cannot be outsourced to
unthinking rules like always write in
the active voice. And now for the third
piece of writing advice that I really
have to circle back on,
I used to think that writers who use
jargon and incomprehensible prose were
doing either one of two things. They
were either showing off or hiding the
fact that they just had nothing to say.
And so every few months, there's a meme
that goes viral where people share an
example from the bad writing in
Here's Judith Butler who won the 1998
competition and then I shared this from
Fredric Jameson with the 1997 passage.
It says, "The visual is essentially
pornographic, which is to say that it
has its end in wrapped mindless
fascination. Thinking about its
attributes becomes an adjunct to that if
it is unwilling to betray its object.
While the most austere films necessarily
draw their energy from the attempt to
repress their own excess rather than
from the more thankless effort to
discipline the viewer." And here's the
winner of the 1998 competition and this
got 300,000 views and 180 shares, so
went viral recently. It says, "The move
from a structuralist account in which
capital is understood to structure
social relations in relatively
homologous ways to a view of hegemony in
which power relations are subject to
repetition, convergence, and
rearticulation brought the That's the
verb, by the way.
Brought the question of temporality into
the thinking of structure and marked a
shift from a form of Althusserian theory
that takes structural totalities as
theoretical objects to one in which the
the insights into the contention
possibility of structure inaugurate a
renewed conception of hegemony as bound
up with the contig- What? Contingent
sites and strategies of the
rearticulation of power. Right, got
that? Good, moving on. People share
passages like this and others to prove
that academics, especially in the
humanities, are frauds. And honestly, I
used to think the same thing. Richard
Feynman said something to the effect of,
"If you can't explain something clearly,
you don't understand it well enough
yourself." And passages like this seem
to be evidence that these academics
didn't have any sense what they were
talking about. They were charlatans. But
here's what changed my mind. So here in
South Korea, I sometimes point out to my
students that if they met somebody from
North Korea, they would understand them.
They speak the same language. But there
would be something subtle about that
person's word choices that would
immediately signal that they're not from
the group. North Korea has, of course,
been largely cut off of global trade and
culture, so its language is basically
frozen in time. So, the Korean spoken in
South Korea has absorbed loan words from
English, German, Japanese, and that's
completely natural. That's the way
language works. Languages are organisms.
They're always evolving and adapting
through these global interactions. So, I
used that to demonstrate the point that
language is not just about information
delivery. It's also social. The words
that you choose say as much about who
you are and who you're speaking to as
they do about what you're saying to
them. So, when somebody complains that
academic writing is exclusionary, then
in a sense, they're right. But they're
describing something we all do every day
in every conversation. We modulate based
on the person we're talking to. We
code-switch depending on the group that
we're in. And we pick words that mark us
as part of the group. And now there's
another meme that pops off sometimes
which picks up on the same point, which
is when people say like, you know, I
accidentally said random instead of
stochastic and they kicked me out of San
Francisco. And this guy says,
"Accidentally said hard instead of
non-trivial and they kicked me out of
San Francisco." Right? Now, that's
really funny, but why is it funny? Well,
it's funny because it's true. Right?
Now, those two words, random and
stochastic, mean roughly the same thing.
But if you're talking to somebody from
San Francisco, which is to say somebody
who's interested in AI and machine
learning and Bayesian reasoning, and you
say the word random, then you are
signaling that you don't quite sit at
their table. Stochastic isn't just a
pompous $50 word, it's a membership
card, it's a signal of in-group status.
But now that said, we do have to come
back to Feynman, because I think he's
also right. If you can't explain
something clearly, then you probably
don't understand it well enough
yourself. Now, I've seen plenty of
amateur academics who hide empty
thinking behind obscurity. But these are
two different things, and we should not
be applying some universal standard
which says that plain English is good
English, and whatever I find obscure is
necessarily empty thinking. All right,
so the real test is, does the writer
know who they're speaking to, and are
they making deliberate choices? So, it's
not really fair to go rooting around in
academic journals to find examples of
language that we, as non-members of that
discourse community, find
incomprehensible. Skilled writers can
switch registers. They can speak to a
specialist and then write a popular book
that applies the same ideas to
mainstream issues. All right, so if
they're using jargon deliberately for
the right audience, then it's not bad
writing, it just means that you probably
weren't the target audience for that
particular text. Now, for the fourth
piece of writing advice that I've really
changed my mind on, every writing
teacher says the same thing. Before you
write, you need to make an outline. And
for a long time, I said this, too. Not
just to my students, but also in my own
writing. So, I've practiced this, as
well. Every time I sat down to write
something for my newsletter or a YouTube
script, I tell myself, all right, three
points, and, you know, outline here, and
then sub-points, and then bullet points
and try to apply these templates to it.
That seemed easy because then writing
just became about filling in the blank
spaces. But what I found through my
experience is that this approach often
led me to writer's block. And that's
funny because it's supposed to do the
opposite. It's supposed to be a sensible
approach, one that would keep the writer
on track and keep them organized. But
I've come to realize that this approach
of doing your outline first and then
writing is the thing that actually
blocks me up. And so the problem with
this advice is that it assumes that
you're done thinking before you started
writing. But that's not how thinking
works. Writing is thinking or at least
it's how thinking becomes visible to
you. So maybe the thinking happens
elsewhere when you're in the shower or
when you're asleep, but the writing is
how you discover what you think and how
you make it legible to yourself. And so
for a good analogy of this, think about
an ant colony. All right, so the
structure of an ant colony is pretty
weird and it's extraordinary, but it's
perfectly suited to the needs of the
colony. It's elegant, it's efficient,
but there's no blueprint and there's no
central planner, no right angles and no
rational grid lines. The structure of an
ant colony emerges from the activity of
the colony itself and it fits perfectly
into the environment, not in spite of
having no plan, but because it was never
forced into one. And so what I've come
to find is that that kind of emergent
structure is what happens in the first
draft when you let it. The real writing
process has two distinct phases, but a
lot of writers collapse them together
into one, which is where the trouble
starts. So the first phase we can call
the artist phase. And so what you can do
here is just set a timer and let
yourself write without direction. Just
pursue your hunches and let yourself get
led to wherever your imagination takes
you. Nobody is going to read this. This
is not for readers. If you feel any
pressure when you're writing this, if
you have a commentary where you say,
"Oh, that's not very good." If you hit
the backspace, that's a sign that you've
already let the judgment of others creep
in and you've got to remove it. The
feeling in this phase of writing should
be freedom. There should be energy and
excitement or calm and kind of the the
the pleasure of focus and flow. Now, one
thing that can be helpful in this phase
of writing is that if you need a tether,
what you can do is write a question at
the top of the page, which is something
that you can return to whenever you feel
lost. So, if you're ever saying, "Oh,
what am I writing about again?" you can
go back to the top of the page, look at
that question, and then resume again.
But, you don't need to have a plan for
where you're going. The reason is your
subconscious already knows the shape of
your ideas. These ideas have been
cooking in the background for quite a
while, and your job in this phase of
writing is just to let them emerge, to
excavate them from deep in your
subconscious. And so, after these timed
writing sessions, whenever you think
you've dredged up enough of your ideas,
then it's time to step back and look at
what's emerged. So, this is the phase of
of the architect. The architect looks
for macro patterns in the artist's text.
So, you analyze it looking for
structures that are native to these
ideas. We are not imposing a structure
from without. We're not trying to fit
those ideas into some outline or
template that you've been given. What
you're doing is looking inside these raw
ideas for the inherent structure, the
major and minor through lines that run
through the text. And then you just
reinforce these through lines through
revision. And so to say that this this
approach of writing an outline first is
wrong, I'm not saying that it's wrong to
have organization. Organization
absolutely matters. There have been
studies that show readers navigate they
they use the same part of their brain to
navigate your text as they do to
navigate through physical space. So they
really are looking for a kind of
hierarchy in your ideas because they're
walking through it almost like a map or
a maze. But the idea that you should
have an outline before you write, that's
what's wrong because that approach asks
you to impose structure before you've
even discovered what you think.
So whatever you're writing, just begin
as an artist and revise as an architect.
That outline, if you need one at all, is
going to come after the first draft. Or
in fact, it's already in the first
draft. You just need to uncover it. And
so the last point that I've really
changed my mind about goes against
something that we hear from a lot of
writing gurus who just tell you, "Don't
worry about your readers. Just write for
yourself." Express what's true for you
and the right people will find it. So
here's David Perell asking Morgan
Housel, "What's the worst piece of
writing advice do you hear?" Housel's
response is, "Know your reader." Now
look, I understand where these guys are
coming from. Because this is actually a
great solution to writer's block and it
sounds liberating. Like no writer, if
you're a writer, wants to be held
hostage to the needs of their readers.
That sounds a little bit too much like
audience capture or like a corporate
style of marketing where you're just
trying to please your readers. But let
me tell you, if you are writing
non-fiction, which is a newsletter, an
essay, a blog, and you actually want to
be read, this advice is leading you
astray. And I believe that this advice
was never actually meant for you. This
is a bad export from the world of
fiction. And so the idea of don't worry
about your readers is connected to a
particular view of the purpose of
writing. People who give this advice
think that the purpose of writing is
self-expression.
Just find a way to communicate whatever
you think is true and then make it
clear, organized, and persuasive. But
think about it. If you write something
clear and useless, it's useless. If you
write something organized and useless,
it's useless. If you write something
persuasive and useless, it's useless.
Nobody has ever sat down with a piece of
writing and thought, "These ideas bore
me to tears, and they have no practical
application to my life whatsoever, but
wow, is this writer ever well
organized." The goal of non-fiction
writing is not to express your ideas.
It's to change the readers' ideas. So
there's a Zen teacher named Thich Nhat
Hanh, and when he was dying, his
disciples wanted to build him a pagoda,
and he really resisted it. He didn't
want them worshipping the finger that
points to the moon. He wanted them to
look at the moon itself. But they
insisted, and so eventually he relented.
And so he said, "If they insist on
building a stupa, then it should have a
plaque that says, 'I'm not here.' But in
case they don't get it, they could add a
second plaque that says, 'I'm not out
there, either.' And if people still
don't understand, then they could add a
third plaque that says, 'If I am
anywhere, I am in your mindful footsteps
and breaths.' And I thought of this
because your ideas are really the same
way. Like go looking for your ideas.
Where are they? They're not in your head
and they're not on the page.
If your ideas exist anywhere, then they
exist only in the mind of your reader.
Because a text that nobody reads is like
the proverbial tree that falls in an
empty forest. Which means whenever
you're assessing a language choice in
your writing, there's only one question
that matters, which is does this move my
reader from where they are to where I
want them to be. Now, after free
writing, whenever you switch hats from
artist to architect, now you're
preparing your text for readers, you
need to ask the following questions
about the person who you're writing for.
What do they currently believe about
this topic? What is the limit of their
knowledge? That is, what do they not
know? What problems are they trying to
solve? And what do I need them to think
differently after reading this? So, that
last question is one that most writers
never ask. Instead, they ask, "Have I
expressed myself clearly?" But the
answer to that question does not produce
value for readers. The goal of your text
is not to express your ideas, it's to
change the ideas of your readers. And
so, those are five pieces of writing
advice that you can retire. But if you
want to know what writing advice
actually holds up, watch this video
next. It's the writing advice that I
keep coming back to. The 20% of tips
that do 80% of the work. So, be sure to
go check it out.